make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and uh credit goes to ant here
for this one uh ant
is a fan on the um on the discord server
who hit me up and said hey man
there is a change in marvel comics about
franklin richards and i was like okay
let's take a look at this let's see
what's going on right so this comes out
on the newest issue of fantastic four
issue number 26 and here's a funny thing
for people who don't know the history of
franklin richards they're freaking out
for people who do know the history about
franklin richards it's like
yeah that kind of makes sense it was
always kind of that way okay so
one of the big changes they made here is
there's a point in the story whereby
franklin is trying to find a way back to
krakowa and he's met by charles xavier
who's reading his mind
and charles xavier says no you cannot
come back to krakow and when franklin
asks the reason why
charles says because you're not a mutant
right according to cerebro you never
have been one that as a child you
dreamed of being different
special without intending to you used
your cosmic powers to alter every cell
in your own body until it appeared as if
you possess
the x gene and so basically he made
himself to look like a mutant right just
kind of masqueraded himself
more or less but he is not inherently a
mutant this is
an accurate statement and in fact it
kind of comes from two different sources
now it wasn't until
we'll talk about whether that changed
here in a minute so uh why the clock
back here right
the clock back to fantastic four annual
number six in fantastic four
issue number 103 now fantastic four
annual number six was written by stan
lee and jack kirby in issue 103 was
written by stan lee and drawn by john uh
john romita but the idea behind this
was that in annual number six that's
when franklin was going to be born right
and what you ended up finding out was
that there were complications
that seemingly the power the i guess the
the cosmic energy
that gave uh susan and reed and those
guys their energy or gave them their
powers was effectively being siphoned
off by franklin
right in the same way that you know a
woman eats food and the baby kind of
consumes it if she doesn't eat enough
it'll cause problems for her it was
basically the same thing with regards to
the energy she had and so in order to
balance those energy levels out
what reed and johnny and ben grimm did
is they travel to the negative zone and
then
grabbing something called the cosmic
control rod and the cosmic control rod
is an artifact in the negative zone
that's in possession of a guy named
nihilus that allows its user to
basically wield cosmic energy
in the most extreme degree right to
basically control the fundamental laws
of the universe itself annihilus uses it
for his own personal
own personal benefit right so like
keeping himself young different things
like that
but when a portion of that energy was
siphoned off by reed and it was brought
to the main marvel universe and given to
susan
that in fantastic four annual number six
a portion of that energy
passed on to franklin and it basically
meant that franklin was born with the
ability to alter matter on a universal
scale to alter matter on the atomic and
subatomic level
now in fantastic four issue number 103
he was handed over to agatha harkness
and in issues 104 105 106 and 107 it was
kind of established that franklin just
sort of had these powers as a result of
the cosmic control rod
but all that changed in fantastic four
issue number 130 when the team's facing
off against the frightful four and the
frightful four has some campaign where
they're trying to get a hold of franklin
and it's established that franklin is a
mutant for the very first time in marvel
comics
following that establishment from that
point going forward marvel always
referred to franklin as a mutant so you
had the original source of his powers
then marvel changed it in issue 130 it
remained the status quo and it has been
ever since and we've seen it in multiple
sources right you see it in house of x
you saw it in
what is it x-men fantastic four or
whatever it was you saw it in
x-men unlimited number 14 back in the
day you saw it in decimation
the decimation storyline the 198 one
shot comic that was like a
list of all the mutants who were out
there that are left and like the most
powerful ones and franklin was listed
among them what happened now
in this particular story is marvel
basically undoing everything that's
happened since
fantastic four annual number six and
basically going back to the original
content so i guess it's true
that like they're making a great big
huge retcon and a rabie cute's change
but not necessarily they're setting
things back to the way they used to be
and that's the big difference here
what you're seeing here is tantamount to
like when captain america steve rogers
lost his super soldier serum he passed
the mantle onto sam wilson who became
the new captain america and then steve
rogers regained a super soldier serum
and went back to being captain america
again right it's a return to the way
things used to be the difference here is
that a lot of people don't know this
history about franklin and so in their
mind it's not necessarily
okay marvel's setting things back to the
way they used to be back during like the
60s and 70s and their mind is marvel's
just changing things willy-nilly and
it's not to say there's anything wrong
with that it's just
not knowing the history of the character
but that's the way those things work you
know that's the way that marvel comics
works marvel comics introduces something
they'll change things up later on
the important thing to understand about
this is that this is the end of dan
slot's run as far as i'm aware i think
we get like a whole new writer and
everything at this point so likely this
won't stay this way forever and in fact
it'll probably go back to things being a
certain way the thing about franklin is
the fact that he was a mutant never
really mattered in marvel comics it was
never really a relevant thing
because you never really saw him doing
things in comics that could only be done
because he was a mutant his ability to
go to krakowa which is where all the
mutants are located at and only mutants
can go there the only reason why him
being a mutant mattered was because of
that story but when you go look at
things like heroes reborn where all this
all the superheroes except for like the
x-men and spider-man
died in a fight against onslaught which
was when like the mind of magneto and
the mind of xavier merged into a
singular being franklin richards
resurrecting them all from the dead and
putting them in a universe that he
created of his own accord had nothing to
do with the fact that he was a mutant
when abraxas was freed right this
representation of like destruction
across the multiverse whatever it was
that he was and abraxas started killing
every version of galactus from across
the color across the multiverse when uh
franklin richards resurrected galactus
from the dead in that story
it had nothing to do with the fact that
he was a mutant when he resurrected
galactus from the dead
and made him into his herald during
hickman's run it had nothing to do with
the fact that he was a mutant so i don't
really understand why people are kind of
getting upset about that the fact that
he's a mutant is irrelevant in the face
of all the things he's done
because it never had anything to do with
anything right it was never a focal
point of that particular story
i mean at the end of the day you know
it's just a thing that he happened to be
but it's it's
it's intriguing to me i'm kind of
curious to see where marvel goes but at
the same time i don't really care
because again it was never really
anything that mattered all i cared about
with franklin was the fact that he could
just do cool stuff
right that's all i cared about that's
the only thing that matters to me and
the the
the fan theory that he controls the
marvel universe those of you guys who
don't know what that means
there is this fan theory that's been
circling circulating around for a number
of years
that if you go and you look at the
publication history of marvel comics
that marvel always referenced current
events right like their stories where
the fantastic four meet with like
richard nixon
and stuff like that who was a president
at the time in a lot of those stories
and then when fantastic four annual
number six happened
that coincided with the publication of
marvel ceasing to reference
modern day events right it was a way for
marvel to kind of suspend disbelief and
just kind of say well comics happen at
any point in time but because of the
fact that marvel stopped referencing
current events after franklin richards
was born
then it led to this fan theory that
franklin richards is the reason why
no one ages he's a reason why everybody
is the same because franklin would have
these moments in his youth when he would
use his powers
like age himself up into an adult
different things like that he would make
some slight alterations or some big
alterations but he wouldn't really know
what he was doing and that on a
subconscious level
franklin wants everything to stay the
way that it is that franklin doesn't
want things to change right so like the
most hardcore of hardcore comic book
fans and the result of this is that
franklin uses powers unwittingly and
basically
froze the entirety of the marvel
universe so that's why spider-man isn't
like 60 years old right now right
which would make sense he'd probably be
older than that like he was a teenager
when he first got his power so fast
forward 40 50 years he'd be in his 70s
if we were following in real time
that's why those things haven't happened
because franklin richards subconsciously
doesn't want them to be that way and so
he keeps things the way that they're the
way that we're used to
just a fan theory i think it's a really
cool one but hopefully this kind of
explains what's going on apparently a
lot of people on twitter are freaking
out but this makes sense to me right i'm
okay with this it makes perfect sense
it's just going back to the original
history of franklin richards back in
fantastic four annual number six the way
he was originally created which is fine
because at the end of the day whether
he's a mutant or not it doesn't matter
he's still a ridiculously overpowered
character and can do pretty much
anything he wants to in the universe so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
come on
[Music]